en el vídeo anterior vimos la
transformada de la plaza de s prima de t
que esto es igual a ese por la
transformada de la plaza de f dt
- efe de 0 ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
usar esta propiedad que sabemos que es
verdad para agregar otros registros a
nuestra tabla de transformadas de
laplace la cual van a tener que
memorizar si es que van a estar
trabajando en alguno u otro momento con
las transformadas de la plaza
vamos a trabajar con esta transformada
de la plaza que sabemos que es verdad y
sabemos que la transformada de la plaza
del seno de aporte es igual y de hecho
recuerdo que fue bastante denso para
encontrar esta transformada de la plaza
es igual a a / s cuadrada más a cuadrada
ahora vamos a usar estas dos cosas que
ya sabemos para encontrar ahora la
transformada de la plaza de joselo de a
d
esto va a ser igual a que bueno vamos a
pensar que este coseno de ate es en
realidad la derivada de una función de
cuál podría ser una derivada a bueno sí
efe prima de té es igual al coseno de
aporte cuál va a ser nuestra potencial
efecto
hoy podría ser una posible efe desde
esto tenemos que encontrar una para la
que esto sea verdad y tenemos que eso es
igual a 1 / a por seno de aporte
por seno de a
muy bien
esto es f prima de t
entonces va a ser igual a s por la
transformada de la plaza
de esta derivada 1 / a porsche no ate
- efe de 0
que es uno entre a por seno de a por
cero que es seno de cero así que se va
de cero es cero este término lo quitamos
así que todo esto va a ser igual a bueno
esto uno entre a es una constante no hay
término desde aquí lo podemos sacar
podemos escribirlo como ese entre a por
la transformada de la plaza de seno de a
t y esto va a ser igual a s / a
por a / s cuadrada masa cuadrada estas
se cancelan y ahora nos va a quedar algo
mucho más simple
nos va a quedar
la transformada de la plaza del cosenos
de porte
va a ser igual a s
/ s cuadrada más cuadrada
y en tres minutos pudimos resolver esta
transformada de la plaza usando cosas
que ya sabemos y que fue mucho más
rápido que cuando quisimos hacer la
transformada de la plaza del seno de
aporte pero bueno vamos a continuar qué
cosas sabemos perdón y bueno nosotros ya
sabemos que la transformada de la plaza
uno es igual a uno en 3
veamos si podemos usar esto y la
transformada de la plaza de f prima que
es igual a s por la transformada de la
plaza de f
- efe de 0
aunque pensándolo bien vamos a
reacomodar todo esto de manera que si
conocemos efe cómo podemos recordar esto
en términos de f prima y f de 0 así que
nos queda la transformada de la plaza de
f prima que podría escribir f dt pero
vamos a ahorrarnos un poco de tiempo más
efe de 0 eso va a ser igual a s por la
transformada de la plaza de f y ahora
vamos a dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre ese y permíteme
intercambiar los lados así que vamos a
tener la transformada de la plaza
también sale un poco checa la l pero
bueno la transformada de la plaza de f
va a ser igual a 1 entre s ya que
dividía ambos lados entre s
la transformada de la plaza
efe prima más efe evaluada en 0
así que vamos a usar esto y esto para
tratar de encontrar otras transformadas
de laplace que nos sean útiles
es la transformada de la plaza d
la transformada de la plaza cuando ft es
igual a t
igual a ti y vamos a usar esta propiedad
esto va a ser igual a 1 entre s por la
transformada de la plaza de la derivada
cuál es la derivada de t abonó la
derivada de te va a ser igual a 1 la
transformada de la plaza de 1 - la
transformada de f de 0 cuando te es
igual a cero esto es igual a cero así
que la transformada de la plaza de te va
a ser igual a 1 entre s ya que la
transformada de la plaza de uno es uno
entre ese uno entre s al cuadrado menos
cero la transformada de la plaza de uno
es uno entre s la transformada de
laplace dt es uno entre ese cuadrado y
ahora vamos a ver la transformada de la
plaza de al cuadrado veamos si aparece
algún patrón la transformada de la plaza
de t
cuadrada va a ser igual a 1 / s x la
transformada de la plaza de la derivada
y cuál es la derivada de t cuadrada
bueno la derivada de cuadradas 2 por t
así que va a ser a transformada de la
plaza de 2 t
esto evaluado en 0 que va a ser igual a
0 así que esto va a ser igual a podemos
quitar esta constante de aquí 2 / s por
la transformada de la plaza de t y todo
esto a que va a ser igual bueno esto ya
lo resolvimos la transformada de la
plaza t es igual a 1 / s cuadrada así
que uno entre s cuadrada por 2 entre s
cuadrada va a ser igual a 2 entre s al
cubo muy bien ahora déjenme hacerles una
pregunta aunque bueno antes de hacer la
pregunta vamos a hacer la transformada
de la plaza de t al cubo y entonces ya
podrán ver si es que surge algún patrón
vamos a hacer entonces la transformada
de la plaza de t al cubo lo cual es
bastante divertido les recomiendo que
ustedes lo hagan
plataforma de la plaza
va a ser igual a 1 / s por la
transformada de la clase 3 por t al
cuadrado
que a su vez es igual a sacamos la
constante 3 entre s por la transformada
de la clase de t al cuadrado
va a ser igual ya lo hicimos es 2 /
desea al cubo que lo multiplicamos por 3
entre s así que nos queda 3 por 2 entre
s a la cuarta aquí se puede ponerte
elevado al adn y hacer un método
inductivo para encontrar una regla
general para esto
creo que ustedes pueden ver el patrón
que está emergiendo aquí vamos a
escribirlo la transformada de la plaza
va a tener aquí una s elevada a un
número grande y la parte de arriba va a
ser el factorial de este exponente
y esta es otra entrada dentro de nuestra
tabla de transformadas de la plaza la
transformada de la plaza de té elevado a
la m
va a ser igual
m factorial /
entre ese elevado a la n zona
m + 1 este es un paréntesis para que se
note
esto pues parecerá una ecuación bastante
intimidante pero realmente no es muy
difícil ya que vimos todo este
desarrollo ya vimos de dónde sale así
que si queremos la transformada de
laplace dt elevado a la 3 lo único que
vamos a hacer es incrementar este
exponente iba a ser ese elevado a la
cuarta que va a ser dividido por el
factorial de 3 así que usamos la
propiedad de derivada de la transformada
de la plaza para encontrar la
transformada de laplace de coseno de
aporte y también la transformada de la
plaza de que elevado a alguna potencia
así que ahora podemos saber la
transformada de la plaza de t elevado a
cualquier potencia y con esto ya sabemos
las funciones trigonométricas la función
exponencial y cómo sacar la transformada
de la plaza de polinomios nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo